hello
hello okay uh hello everyone uh welcome
to the Swift as C++ successor in FDB
Foundation DB talk my name is Conrad I
work at Apple on the Swift team mostly
focus on language and runtime for
concurrency and distributed systems but
also server side libraries in general uh
so this talk is a bit of a case study
how we adopted Swift in a large existing
code base uh that's predominantly C++
and I'll introduce you to some Swift
features along the
way uh so for those who don't know uh
Swift is a natively compiled general
purpose language it's the language of
choice on Apple
platforms uh but it's equally well
supported on other platforms for example
Linux and there a vibrant service side
ecosystem people building and deploying
services in in
Swift uh in general we have a very
strong focus on safety both memory
safety and currency safety and I'll zoom
into to this a bit more at the same time
though Swift doesn't sacrifice
ergonomics to achieve this safety uh we
strive to be a great first programming
language you can imagine you've never
programmed before you want to pick up
some language write an app for your
phone it can't overwhelm beginners with
a ton of difficult stuff right at the
same time we have use cases that are
really soft re time systems system
libraries or even the kernel but also
want to be using
Swift uh so we really have to scale from
the simplest Beginnings to the most most
advanced use cases in the same language
and to do that um Swift is really
optimized for both performance and
predictability You can predict where and
how things are going to be allocated
there's no GC with unpredictable
behaviors and the overhead of the
runtime is generally very low and it's
evolved using a open uh de development
process you can propose things to the
language
uh just as a community member um so I
should probably Define what I mean when
we say uh successor language so
successor language uh generally we think
it's whenever you're about to use C++
you should think again and use Swift uh
so predecessor languages in our mind are
C and C++ the predominant uh reason to
build a successor language is safety so
we want to entirely eliminate an entire
class of
predominantly memory and concurrency
safety ones because they can manifest as
security issues so this is something we
really want to eliminate as much as
possible we can't really just patch up
C++ because well it's going to be
patched up C++ and the core of C++ the
way it manages memory and all these um
easy to make mistakes would be still
there so we want to clean cut between
safe by default languages Swift and the
predecessor languages
and Swift has a great story for
interrupting with C it was a key for its
success on Apple platforms and we've
really focused on that and we've brought
the same experience to the C++
inability uh in this year's
release and to finally introduce our
latest actor in Last actor in this uh
show uh Foundation DB so Foundation DB
is a open source uh key value data store
it has distributed transactions over uh
multiple keys
and it is um sorry
and yeah it's open source and was
acquired by Apple a few years ago um
Foundation DB is in the critical path
every time you're using iCloud for
signing in accessing your email contacts
so it's a massively critical service for
Apple it's also used by other companies
like Snowflake and others a crucial
piece of what makes FDB so interesting
and successful is it um simulation
testing run time so fdp is able to run
millions and millions of tests with you
know injecting failures reordering
messages injecting delays kind of a
chaos testing environment but as it does
so and finds an issue we're able to
reproduce the exact execution of the
entire program to reproduce the same
issue so you can reproduce how did this
crazy Edge case happen and you can have
it reproduce every single time and find
the issue so really amazing for finding
bch cases uh this is made possible by a
custom language called flow flow is a
C++ dialect and was developed along with
FDB so it's more than 10 years old by
now uh it's a C++ dialect in the sense
that it adds a few keywords and syntax
to C++ but actually it's not really a
full-blown language but a source
generator that generates C++ from those
extra
pieces um it's really what kind of
enabled this simulation testing runtime
because it has all the hooks where we
can inject all of these
reorderings um so it's probably fair to
say that Foundation DP is really made
possible by this tight integration of
the language the concurrency runtime and
this testing facility so it's really
something really enabled by flow at the
same time it's been 10 years since flow
was first introduced and FDB are looking
to kind of modernize and improve uh from
the things that are kind of starting to
show its age so the FDB team went
through and thought about okay what do
we need to improve for another 10 years
of successful database right
um and the first and predominant issue
here is the memory on safety of C++ uh
we really want to have a environment
where we can be more reliant on the
language providing us help with
development and not fight the language
and you know trying to prevent all these
bus um the other issues are that the
flow language is kind of a side product
and it being a source generator is kind
of showing its limits the amount of nice
Diagnostics and features you can do as
just a source text based Source
generator fairly limited and the runtime
is limited to being single threaded you
cannot go multi threaded with flow it
just wouldn't work uh so we also should
do something about that because Modern
Hardware things have changed in the last
10 years we really want to use m core
even though initially it was a good idea
to be single threed and uh the usual of
debugging C++ programs and debugging
concurrency Plus+ programs it's a
hindrance on adoption hiring and
debugging just loss of developer
productivity so that's things the team
would like to address and they came to
us for Swift team saying well we heard
Swift has actors and all these nice
things maybe we can replace flow but as
we look at these requirements it turns
out outfit well we're not actually
trying to replace flow here because in
order to get memory safety congruency
safety it wouldn't really matter if you
change the source generator you still
have C++ and it still has all these
issues so we're actually looking at an
exercise of replacing C++ and that is
one of the things Swift is good at um
and it's another great case to showcase
our C++ inter so that's what we did uh
there's a PR here that is merged in the
Upstream Foundation DB Repository
and we started an incremental adoption
of Swift side by side the existing C++
code
base okay uh so to reform these
requirements that were stated before
into a few steps that we can walk
through uh we'll have to start with
actually being able to compile Swift
together with the C++ Cod
base as many C++ uh projects FDB is
built using cmake a typical cmake file
just declares a bunch of modules and
and uh thankfully Swift will be able to
just uh consume clang modules um our
goal here is to be able to plop in uh
Swift files right next to the C++ files
because this way we're able to see okay
the for example Master server Swift oh
so we started we started migrating this
file this actor into Swift uh you could
totally have a totally separate module
where you put all of the Swift files uh
but that's really up to how you organize
your cake project we thought this is
more interesting because uh visually you
have direct feedback oh uh I can uh
already use some Swift thing Swift
here um so building Swift uh of course
we have our own package and manager that
can build and download dependencies run
tests as you would expect but we can't
be using that here because we want to
incrementally add Swift to this existing
build with as little fluff and break
everything along the way as possible
right so instead what we'll do is we'll
use cake to build Swift and the good
news is that cake actually has builds in
support for Swift and all you need to do
is in your project say language Swift
and you can start adding Swift files to
a cmake build um worth noting is that
some uh libraries actually are even
built using cake themselves so both
using the Swift package manager and cake
so if you wanted to pull in some of the
popular like better collections that are
a bit more than the standard Library
offers atomics libraries or many others
you can actually do this using cmake as
well so let's uh include some Swift
files in our FDB build to do that we add
a new library that's how you declare a
Target in cake we call it FDB server
undor Swift to mirror the FDB server
Target and you just start adding Swift
files there uh we make this all of these
Swift modules uh dependency of the FDB
server the C++ Target
and that's really all we need to do then
we can open up our Swift file and write
some Swift that actually uses C++ types
so when you see these import flow import
FDB client those are actually importing
C++ targets and all the blue types here
some master data the request here all
the function calls here are actually
coming directly from
C++ uh so as this is the first time
we're calling C++ in this talk let me
explain how this actually
works so as I just said you can import
existing clang modules and clang modules
are basically just a collection of C++
header files uh the Swift compiler is
able to understand header files and this
way uh we basically know oh there's a
get server knobs function but it's it
gets uh much more interesting than that
because as for Swift compiler is
importing this
module it can actually inline function
bodies because both clang so the C++
compiler and Swift are operating on llvm
and what actually is emitted during
compilation is llvm's intermediate
representation so what Swift C does is
ask clang that hey can you please emit
this inline function body in into my
compilation unit and it is the actual
lvm intermediate representation being
emitted directly into the Swift binary
or Library um
and because the llvm optimizer also
works on this layer of abstraction so
the llvm's IR it can even optimize
across the languages for example if you
had a few calls calling here there was
some null checks maybe it could
automatically realize hm even though
there's a language barrier here lvm
doesn't really care it can optimize as
if there wasn't a barrier at all so in
that sense it's a bit unfair to call it
just an interrupt feature because it's
much more it's not a IFI there's no
wrappers there's no bindings you have to
generate you're literally calling the
C++ code directly from
Swift okay let's uh look at the other
way so let's say you have some C++ code
and you want to call Swift and we'll
have some Swift function implemented
here that we want to call um the way you
do that is you include a Swift uh
generated header so as Swift compiles in
the interrupt mode it generates a header
that C++ can understand for all the
public declarations so we just import
that header and we can call the Swift
function as far as C++ is concerned this
is normal C++ code there's nothing
magical about it so everything works as
you would expect we can pass C++ um C++
pointers here and it will end up just
calling vwi
function uh yep so here we're returning
a future that's also a C++ type and then
we use Flow Away on it okay let's talk a
little bit more about the language model
about the object model of both of these
languages and how they can
interrupt uh first let me introduce
Swift a little bit so Swift leans
heavily on value types uh so value types
you can think of them as behaving the
same as a primitive so for example here
we have a wrapper struct it has a value
inside and we're also modeling mutation
explicitly in Swift so you can see
there's a let declaration and then a VAR
copy so semantically there will be a
copy performed when we do this VAR copy
assignment and as you can see trying to
mutate a let assignment is not allowed
by the compiler but of course you can
mutate the copy and not affect the
original value that's what we mean by
value semantics this is great um for all
kinds of reasons just local
understanding of your code not
accidentally mutating something you
didn't intend to it's also great for
concurrency because if everybody has
their own copy there's not shared
mutable State everybody's
happy we do a bit more than that though
and I would like to introduce you to
copy on right value types for example
collections in Swift such as arrays
dictionaries and sets are also value
types and you might be thinking well
isn't that a horrible idea because we
would have to be copying the entire
array all the time when passing it
around so instead of course we don't do
that that would be silly instead what we
do is when the collection is unique
referenced we can mutate them in place
and as they are passed around here we
have two functions uh called pass and
mutate please as you pass these uh items
array around it still isn't copied it is
only copied once you try to well once
you attempt to mutate right so uh at the
bottommost function here we have VAR C
items that still didn't copy although
semantically you can imagine as if it
did but as you do see a pent that is
where the copy is made and from this
point on you have your unique storage
and further mutations are made in place
it's a really powerful uh semantic that
we use in a lot of types in
Swift and of course we have uh reference
types reference types use reference
counting Atomic reference counting in
Swift so uh you get predictable Char
characteristics on that and you cannot
really have a null pointer per se if you
wanted to express nullability we force
you into using optional types and
actually unre mapping
safely okay uh let's compare it to C++
and see how things can import across
languages so a C++ structor class
Imports as a value type by default and
usually that's the right thing to do so
it would just use the C++ types uh copy
Constructor and if a copy Constructor is
deleted well clearly we can't be copying
it so we will not import that
type on the other hand a C++ reference
type is a is a bit more importing A++
reference type is a bit more involved
and this is primarily because it's not
really clear uh from looking at the
Declaration side of a type like here
this Global
counter is it a reference type C++
doesn't really well specify that and
it's more about how you pass things
around and how you allocate them where
you can notice oh it's intended to be
used as a reference right so you you
pass it around as a pointer a shared
pointer but in the same code base
totally could have an a function
accepting a value of that struct it's
technically not incorrect but uh the
compiler wouldn't really know what to do
with this so we need a little bit of uh
input from the from the developer and
the way you do this is including the
Swift bridging header which includes a
bunch of uh macro annotations that you
can put on your types and then declare
okay so the global counter I know this
is something that we allocate once it's
a global thing a global Singleton so
just assume it's a reference and don't
even perform any ref counting on it I
know this is going to live forever uh so
this way the way this is imported into
Swift it's going to be treated as a
reference of course that's for easy path
uh that's the simplest case because we
didn't actually ref count it uh more
interestingly we would like to import
types and actually ref count foreign
types declared in in C++ like the master
data here from the FDB code base so as
I'm done using it I want it to be
deallocated released right if we look at
the Declaration of it in C++ we can see
that okay it's non-copyable and it's uh
reference counted okay what is reference
counted reference counted is a custom
implementation of intrusive reference
counting that FDB has uh defined and the
reason they do that is because well
sometimes it's a threet unsafe because
we know we are a single threet at
runtime we don't have to use atomics
here so they can r Ry on uh using that
although there's Atomic version as
well now this is just an example of a
typical thing that happens in C++ code
bases which is a lot of weird custom
stuff to manage memory and every code
base will have its own slightly
different uh approach to this and the
important thing with the interrupt
feature for Swift is so we can support
all kinds of these patterns so what we
can do again is to bring in this Swift
bridging header
and declare okay this is going to be a
shared reference and whenever you want
to retain or or release an instance of
this class struct uh call these
functions this informs the Swift
compiler when using this type in Swift
to call these native C++ functions to
retain and release this object so we're
automatically going to manage the
lifetime for you here using whatever ref
reference counting scheme you have in
C++
that is not all though and we should do
a bit better than that really because
okay we can call methods uh we can refer
to types but if the usage of those
foreign types doesn't feel natural it
will be kind of weird right and people
will be like H maybe I'll stick to C++
but our goal is to eventually replace
more and more code with swift because we
want for safety properties so not only
does it have to kind of just work it has
to feel great so people are incentivized
to use more Swift than C++ right and
we're not used to it so the easier we
can make it the
better okay uh so there's three pieces
to that I want to highlight uh memory
safety and object lifetime we just
talked about as long as you annotate
your types correctly this will just work
uh next uh worth highlighting is
collections or C++ containers STD
containers Because by the end of the day
we use a lot of collections in our code
bases every single day and we usually
have some kind of niceties in the
languages we use as well right so
thankfully uh Swift is able to import
collections SL containers and you're
able to use an STD Vector in a swift for
Loop or use for each or filter methods
you would expect from Swift to be able
to call on these collections right at
the same time methods that are just did
Vector methods are also available so you
can use whatever fields right the same
is true for dictionary types like map
and here the interesting bit is that uh
yes we're using a subscript to get
something out of this map however this
is going to return a swift optional so
again you're not going to have to deal
with uh safety of those accesses it's
going to force you into the you have to
check
right and perhaps most interestingly and
the use case I want to dive deep into is
how we want to interact with concurrent
declared on this on the C++ side and the
tricky thing here is that uh C++ doesn't
really have one way to do concurrency
you might be using various libraries
maybe some are using Futures maybe you
wrote your own things and this is the
case in FDB where um the flow Li the
flow language and Library come with
their own definitions of Futures and
promises and this is the primary way you
do async and flow um
so of course as we call these functions
uh declared in C++ using the flow
Library Swift wouldn't really know how
to treat this and magically turn this
into an as8 core but this is what we
idiomatically would like to do and Swift
for idiomatic way to do such a call
would be to await a asynchronous
function right but we can't write such a
function in C++ so how can we do
that uh before we jump to the solution
let me introduce you to two Swift
features one is extensions uh so
extensions allow you to add methods to
existing types even if they're declared
in other modules so you can just write
an extension on the notified version
value and we can Implement our uh at
least a synchronous function in Swift
that's one way to do it um we can do a
bit better than vfo and we can declare a
protocol that is similar to interfaces
in other languages in the sense that
it's going to declare okay things
conforming to this protocol will have to
provide implementations of an at least
asnc function so we can declare this so
we have an API contract and then we can
post hog conform an existing type to
this protocol so we take uh this C++
notified version value we conform it to
the notified
operations okay the compiler will now
demand from us that we provide an
implementation for this at least asnc
function but instead of providing it for
this concrete type we can provide it for
all kinds of uh notified operations
right so this way we are able to
implement this bridging code in one
place and then every uh conforming type
is able to get the implementation for
free uh let's have a look at how we
would implement this uh this at least
function so to implement it uh basically
we can direct to the C++ implementation
get the future out of it and then wait
do value on it uh but wait wait wait
where does the dot value function come
from right uh I didn't actually Define
it and if this going to be one of those
where okay for every single type we have
to go deeper and deeper and keep adding
functions one by one uh thankfully no
and I want to show you specifically on
the future type what we can do better
here so the future type as you might
expect is a class template because
there's various Futures future of in
future of void and and while we cannot
directly extend it in Swift today we can
ask the compiler that well while you're
importing this type or instantiations of
this template I should say please
conform it to this protocol then we can
express uh just enough in the Swift type
system uh to uh have enough to be able
to implement a generic value
implementation and make sure that the
Swift that the Swift requirements match
up with the c Plus+ types
implementations so yes you do have to uh
spell out the spellings of those methods
in Swift but thankfully you can always
look up how swift sees a C++ interface
by opening up a imported module file uh
so you can uh easily find that
out so now we can write an extension on
our F flow future operations and provide
this value implementation the
implementation itself isn't too exciting
uh it's a lot of boilerplate but the
point being
uh and it doesn't really use anything we
didn't discuss so I'm going to skip it
you can find the implementation though
if you want in the repo uh the point
being though is for every instantiation
now as we're importing those types into
Swift the compiler will also conform it
to this protocol by by mean but because
this protocol has this default
implementation of the value we can just
call it on whatever future we might be
using in our
codebase so we're able to write this
code basically
and there's kind of layers to how much
effort we want to spend for the future
type we we went all the way in with this
protocol conformance and default
implementation because Futures are used
everywhere in the code base but at the
same time we could have uh still just
said when at least and then do the dot
value but we can also provide nicer apis
that look more idiomatic uh when it's
worth doing so and I think it is worth
doing so because the more uh nice it
feels to write code into the successor
language the more interested you are in
using it right so small things like that
pay up in the grand scheme of things and
the best thing of course is that the
nasty implementation is hidden away in
one place you don't have to every single
time you use a future do a bunch of
workarounds uh so that's really
important uh next up let's talk about
concurrency so concurrency has its own
set of challenges and again our Focus
will be on safety and ergonomics we need
to improve both of them
and improve both upon the C++ unsafety
and we have to integrate with this
existing FDB runtime that I told you
about for uh simulation testing so how
can we do
that uh before we jump in uh let me
introduce a typical kind of race or
question that might arise in C++ code
the illustrating code is in this flow
language but conceptually it's just two
actors which may execute concurrently
the force recovery actor and the track
recovery reactor and they're both
referring to this shared reference to a
mutable State now I named it here pretty
obviously that o mutable State this
might be not a good idea but in a real
code base it might be hard to spot is
this a correct access or not and if you
were to ask the question well is this
safe to share this reference between
these actors the answer would kind of
depend on both who you're asking if the
person is EXP experienced or not with
this specific code base or if they've
had their coffee or not right maybe
they're too sleepy oh yeah it's fine
whatever so the problem here is that
it's up to the developer to double check
every single line of code and uh verify
oh this probably is correct right uh in
the FDB case uh there's kind of a weird
answer here that on a lowlevel
concurrency level because the runtime is
single threaded sure this won't cause
like memory corruption or r RIS in that
sense however it still might not be
intentional that this mutable share
state was actually shared between the
actors and you can't really know right
you would have to go in and start some
detective work if this was intentional
or not so this is a problem because FDB
would like to use more concurrency in
the system but we don't really have a
way to gain more confidence in this
unchecked
word uh so yeah we introduced actors but
because it's still C++ we're still
wrangling with the same old issues of
non- checked uh concurrency basically so
here's how swift fits into the picture
so Swift's approach is to be safe by
default uh we mean that about both
memory and concurrency so we achieve at
four concurrency with compile time
checking uh so actro isolation and
sendable checking both come together and
basically make it impossible to write
incorrect
code some sometimes when we're unable to
uh conf confirm if something is safe or
not at compile time which is actually
very rarely uh we would insert runtime
checks but uh that's as a fallback I
mostly mention that to highlight that we
will value safety more than anything and
yes it's going to be opt out but the
kind of default mode is switched from
the predecessor languages where the
default mode is oh nothing is safe good
luck for us safe is a
default uh so Swift actors uh actors
have been around for a long time and
implemented in many languages and
libraries and as you've seen here uh fdp
also implemented them more than 10 years
ago as a library solution now the
problem with Library solutions to actors
is that you're still on the host
language and the host language will have
concurrency holdes in it as another
example my previous life before the
Swift team was working on aka the kind
of actors on the jvm and it's also a
langu it's also a library solution and
and while you stay in the correct
patterns to use AR actors you're safe
but the moment you touch a Scala future
type inside an actor oh suddenly you
broke concurrency right because we can't
prevent you from doing unsafe things as
a library but as a language as Swift is
we can so let me introduce you to
that uh to introduce an actor in Swift
is very easy instead of having a
reference type like a class you can make
it into an
actor now the compiler will start
emitting warnings and errors in all
kinds of places because now you're
probably violating uh actor access rules
uh actor isolation for example here we
have a counter and we're hitting the
counter to increment its count and the
compiler says well but this is acing
because interacting with actors the
actor might be already doing something
so we may have to suspend you uh so you
have to acknowledge that by writing a
weight because this is a potential
suspension point we call those potential
suspension points because there are
actually cases in which we don't have to
suspend then can call directly but
that's dependent on a few executor
details so you can treat it as an
optimization um and if we were to model
the previous example here uh using Swift
actors this is what it would look like
uh so we have a recovery actor we have a
recovery tracker and I'm trying to
escape the self State uh and the
compiler will tell you that hey you're
trying to send a non sendable type
mutable State into an actor isolated
domain you probably introduce the data
race here uh today this is a warning we
will be upgrading all of these into hard
errors in the upcoming uh major
release uh and I would like to highlight
that well the previous example was kind
of easy we just escaped a variable in
the call but this is very deeply
integrated into the language including
Escape analysis enclosures and for
example if you had a listener type that
has a call me lator that takes a closure
it depends how this closure is being
used if this code is correct or not if
you're guaranteed to synchronously
invoke this closure then this code is
correct but if it's actually going to
escape this closure and use it somewhere
else to then later call you on a
different actor or Fred this is unsafe
so the compiler can holistically analyze
and by annotating code correctly you're
able to get help from the compiler if
you actually would want to share the
state uh the recommended way would be
really to make it a struct because
that's easy to thanks to Value semantics
you can very easily then send it around
or you can use actor isolation and make
other code run on the same actor by and
then by using ACT the actor semantics of
only one thing runs congruently at a
time on an actor you would also be safe
and could still be using the mutable
State uh an interesting thing here is
that you can actually declare new
methods on actors using uh extensions
and this is interesting because there's
a duality between access control and
kind of concurrency control because what
we just did here is this entire function
will be running on the actor and we can
for example flip a few things on the
actor's internal State without hopping
of it so we get atomicity as we do these
updates that's something not many other
actor times can do um to me that's very
exciting so uh to compare this again to
the existing state of foundation DB uh
Foundation DBS actors are a bit of a
pattern really so you see there's these
few returning functions and they have to
pass around the self object because it's
kind of representing the this of the
actor uh if we were to turn this into
Swift uh firstly okay it looks a bit
more like normal code words were used to
reading but primarily we already got the
gain of actual isolation checking so all
this stuff about oh you can't escape
values you have to go async to access it
we already gotten benefit
here
um now we can Implement a concrete
function so I can show you how to use
actors from C++ so here we have our uh
Master Data actor and we're implementing
the good version function and to export
this actor to C++ uh which is down below
trying to use it uh all we have to do is
to make the actor public uh for C++ this
looks and behaves just like a reference
type but it will not be able to call the
async function because C++ doesn't
really have that notion of async
function
so yes we would have to write a little
bit of boiler plate to bridge our async
code into the world of flows Futures and
Promises so that's that's unfortunate so
we would have to write this piece of
boiler plate for every single function
we're exposing to flow it's not so great
but thankfully again Swift has us
covered because we can use a macro for
this uh Swift macros new inv this
release um are syntactic macros they
work on the A and uh unlock like C++
macros where you can pretty much
generate uh well not random but pretty
free form things this is based on a
abstractions that you can very easily
manipulate and so we can do that in a
micro and finally uh I said that uh FDB
has this concurrency testing runtime how
it works in practice is uh the source
generator splits up this function into
various classes with State machines
inside them that that represent jobs
that are submitted to an event Loop that
event Loop can be either the simulation
testing one or the production one and as
long as we were able would be able to
submit jobs into this existing runtime
it would basically work because it's
just a runtime that H I'm going to delay
this job a little bit or H I'm going to
reorder these jobs a little bit
so Swift is actually quite similar to
that because we have tasks and jobs
which um we have a hook for for that we
have overridden to then instead of
submitting jobs into Swift's concurrency
pool can basically wrap the existing
Swift tasks and jobs into a type that
already exists in the FDB code base and
whenever the FDB event Loop tries to run
them well we're going to call Swift run
on the job instead so the integration
here was fairly easy
surprisingly and last but not least uh
to continue the thread on developer
experience uh of course uh all of this
Swift and C++ INR works great in xcode
but we know that uh people use various
IDs so we have a language server
implementation for Swift and you can use
whatever ID you like you can use uh vs
code VM emx whatever has a v uh LSP
client and to Showcase this in Action a
little bit use a screenshot of vs code
with the um sswg so uh server server
side work group uh serers side Swift
workg group maintained plugin and that
plugin uses this LSP server to uh
provide a nice developer experience and
you can see it both a complete Swift
types and types coming from C++ in a
swift Ty in a Swift uh file that can
autoc complete and
everything and the last thing I want to
cover
is um developer experience of debugging
crashes so here's how a crash looks like
today on Foundation DB
and you know typical for a C++ program
it would crash and give you way to well
if you still have the debug binary you
can use this commands to get a back race
so you take this command you run it if
you're lucky enough to still have a a
binary Ling around and then you have to
play with uh uh finding your code
because it's all Source generated and
actually mapping your code to the back
Trace is not going to be uh trivial but
eventually you will find the code right
so that's a complaint about the source
generation aspect but the real issue
here isn't about the source generation
but about um Futures and Promises
themselves if you have a chain of
Futures and Promises so here we have two
promises and then we take one succeed it
as this first one succeeds we succeed
the second one so we kind of cascade the
value up up a chain of Futures up a
chain of promises and then in the second
one we crash if we got some bad value
um the way a back trace for such a thing
would look like regardless of Futures
implementation really is something like
this a lot of Library code and yes
finally you will get your line with the
crash but you will never get the line
you're actually looking for which is
where did this G bad value come from
right so in future implementations you
don't really get the entire context you
only get the oh this is the crash site
so that's pretty frustrating and let's
compare that what to what we can do in
Swift so in this example I have a task
that then calls an async function calls
an a racing function called check and
we're even calling into some C code here
that will eventually
crash uh this is how the backies would
look like for this so instead of having
to guess around where the code was
actually crashing I hope this is large
enough it should be uh you get a full
back Trace in spanning multiple
languages we're going to include the C C
or C++ code where you actually crashed
and then continue through the
asynchronous suspension points so oh
sorry I should mention uh we're going to
demangle the C++ symbols as well if you
have them here uh include Source
location and uh the back Trace is
logical so we're actually going to
follow through all of the suspension
points so this is uh to counterpart the
counterpart of the problem with Futures
where you wouldn't find find out where
the bad value came from with a syn we
and few uh our back Tracer following
stack frames like this we're able to
give you the entire logical okay this is
why you why you have a bad value
somewhere and you can even drop into the
debugger right away so we will keep the
process alive you won't have to oh no
now I have to reproduce the same with a
debugger attached right so you can
immediately drop in and
debug so to wrap up I know I'm at time
so let's keep it quick uh Swift really
uh uh was able to address all of the
issues that we stated at the beginning
we get memory safety concurrency safety
and it's all in the existing code base
um we do this uh we focus on safety and
ergonomics but we don't sacrifice
performance and while I didn't talk
about performance much here in this talk
as we migrated these important core
actors in The FDB code base and used
existing benchmarks for exercise them we
saw no regressions whatsoever so if
someone is using the excuse of oh we
have to write C++ because performance
they might have to double check that
assumption and we really think Swift is
a viable alternative
here
um one last thing I want to highlight is
that it's not that oh we did this
special thing for the FDB project is
more that this is a Strategic investment
for C++ inw because we really want a
successor language to replace C and C++
and the FDB project was just a great uh
example to uh showcase all of that and
it's open source so you can check it out
which is another great
extra um Swift has a C++ successor yeah
we talked about that
um just checking if I any yeah so the
last thing I wanted to say yeah if
you're considering or still using C++ uh
please give Swift a look and it's not
just limited to being a C++ replacement
it's a totally viable uh just language
on its own so while we talked about C++
today by itself I hope the actra things
and safety uh is probably very
interesting for you all to check out so
thank you very much and yeah here's some
links you can check out thank
[Applause]
you